في تطور جديد ولافت في مجريات الحرب في
اوكرانيا قال حاكم مدينه
شبهي جزيره القرم ان القوات الاوكرانيه
شنت هجوما على مقر الاسطول الروسي في
البحر الاسود واضاف الحاكم ان شظايا سقطت
في وسط المدينه بعد استهداف مقر الاصول من
جانبها اعلن السلطات القرم وقوع ست اصابات
جرى الهجوم وطلبت من السكان تجنب الشوارع
الرئيسيه في المدينه تحسبا لوقوع هجوم
اوكرانيا اخر وفي وقت لاحق اعلنت السلطات
اعاده افتتاح جسر القرن الذي يربط المنطقه
بالبر الروسي بعد حظر الحركه لفتره وجيزه
عقب الهجوم
معنى الان من موسكو مراسله الجزيره سامر
يوسف ومن ذا فولوجيا مراسله الجزيره ليس
كرام ارحب بكما ابدا معك سامر يوسف عن اي
بيانات رسميه تطرقت الى هذا التطور
المتعلق
[تصفيق]
السلطات الروسيه في القرمه ازدهار تتحدث
عن ازاله الخطر جزئيا حتى هذه اللحظه هذا
ما يمكن وصفه بحسب حاكم
الروسي ولكن قال بانه يدعو المواطنين الى
عدم التوجه حتى اللحظه الى مراكز الحادث
تم ايقاف صافرات الانذار التي انطلقت
لتحذر من هجوم اخر محتمل كما قال قبل نصف
ساعه من الان حاكم
الروسي ولكن يبدو بان الامور تبدو تحت
السيطره هناك لم يتم الاعلان من الجانب
الروسي هنا في موسكو عن قتلى او عن اعداد
ضحايا سقطوا ولكن المعلومات التي تردنا من
هناك وبعض الصور تشير الى ان مركز المدينه
تضرر ايضا وهناك حاله من الدعر بين
المدنيين لذلك تم الطلب من المدنيين بعدم
التحرك وحتى هذه اللحظه كما اسلفت ازدهار
شبه جزيره القرم والجسر الرئيسي الخاص بها
اعيد فتحه بعد ان اغلق بشكل مؤقت نتيجه
استهداف الاسطول البحري هناك اسطول البحر
الاسود
الروسي الذي يعتبر من الوحدات الضخمه
للبحريه الروسيه التي تتواجد هناك ومهمتها
في البحر الاسود وحتى في
البحر الابيض المتوسط كانت هناك ايضا
تحذيرات في المقابل من هجوم اخر
هل من جديد بهذا الخصوص
كما اسلفت ازدهار صافرات الانذار التي
انطلقت بعد الهجوم او اثناء الهجوم الاول
استمرت لدقائق عده ولكن يبدو انها توقفت
الان بحسب المعلومات الوارده من هناك بحسب
شهود عيان ووسائل اعلام ما يعني بان
الهجوم الاخر يبدو مستبعدا الان ولكن
التحذيرات الامنيه من قبل السلطات الروسيه
في القرن ما زالت قائمه وتطلب من
المواطنين والمدنيين بعدم التحرك الى مركز
المدينه والبقاء في المباني السكنيه والى
اخلاء المراكز
المدنيه في شبه جزيره القرم ولكن عمليا
يبدو بان مساله الهجوم الاخر لا تبدو
وارده الان اذا فقط للتذكير فان حاكم
مدينه سلفا ستوبل اتهم بشكل مباشر القوات
الاوكرانيه في تنفيذ هذا
الهجوم هنا انتقل اليك الياس كرم اي تفاعل
اوكراني مع هذه الروايه
حتى هذه الساعه ازدهار لا يوجد اي تعليق
سياسي او عسكري حول هذا الهجوم لكن من
الواضح بان لم يعد سرا ولا خافيا على ان
اوكرانيا هي منطقه وراء تلك العمليات التي
تستهدف القواعد العسكريه الروسيه في القرن
وكذلك القواعد والعتاد العسكري في تلك
المنطقه وقد اعترفت القيادات العسكريه
والاستخباراتيه الاوكرانيه في ماضي الايام
في الايام الماضيه عن عده استهدافات
وعمليات نوعيه استهدفت مقر تابعه لقياده
الاسطول اسطول البحر الاسود وكذلك مطارات
عسكريه روسيه في القرن مشير هنا الى ان
بعض التقديرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه تشير
الى ان الهجوم الذي نفذ في الساعات
الاخيره على القرن وعلى مقر قياده الاسطول
الروسي هناك جاءت بعد ان كانت
المسلحه الاوكرانيه في الايام الماضيه قد
نفذت هجمات طالت بعض منصات الرادارات
ومنظومات اس 3 اس 400 هذه المنظومات
الدفاعيه الجويه وهذا ما ربما ما هذا لهذه
الضربه العسكريه الاوكرانيه على هذا
المقر لكن نشير هنا الى ان هذه ليست
العمليه النوعيه الاولى الايام الماضيه
شهدت العديد من العمليات النوعيه التي
نفذتها البحريه الاوكرانيه بالتعاون مع
قوات خاصه ومع الامن المركزي الاوكراني اس
بي يو ومن اهم وابرز هذه العمليات
الاستيلاء على منصات الغاز في البحر
الاسود من خلال عمليه خاصه كانت تسللت
مجموعه من البحريه الاوكرانيه الى مقربه
من شواطئ شبه جزيره القرم وقامت الضفادع
البشريه التابعه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه
ربما تركيب بعض الاجهزه الاستشعاريه على
سفينه وغواصه روسيه كانت في الميناء
الحربي هذه الاستشعارات وجهت الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه صوبه اهدافها بدقه بحسب
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه هذا بالاضافه
ايضا الى الاستيلاء كما اشرت على منصات
الغاز التي استخدمتها روسيا كمنصات
وكمنطلق لتنفيذها هجمات في المحاور
الجنوبيه للقتال
كرام ومن موسكو شكرا جزيلا لكما